what what leadership lessons do you have
when you look at yourself as a platoon
commander in charge of eight birds
to battalion commander so
first of all you know i i believe
that leadership is a learned skill not a
natural skill and that those
the skill sets required at different
levels change
right so as a pl a platoon leader right
it's direct leadership
jocko follow me you know um we're going
here we're doing that
right and you and your troop
but as you get more senior now you've
got these layers of bureaucracy in
between you
right and you know think back to when
you're a young
0-102 down in the teams and he got you
know that
ancient dude who's an 05 up there right
and it was clearly clueless because
everybody who's above you is clueless
right that's a
you know common hell belief by all and
and you know i just kept learning you
know so when i was remember i told you i
was really worried about chronic fatigue
and
morale and you know families or fran
because of what's
this op tempo so that
uh warrant i was telling you about carl
meyer who was a little bird driver and
his
wife cindy who i'm still friends with to
this day
one day i was walking around the hangar
and and she said you know you ought to
go spend some time with these young
troops
you know because they want to hear from
the battalion commander what's happening
you know
and it really resonated with me so i
blocked out
and this is a small leadership technique
but it was very effective for me i
blocked out two hours a week
and i went and i never told anybody
where i was going and it wasn't an
inspection right i wasn't coming over
there and saying well nick why do you
got a croakie on your
freaking sunglasses it was more you know
just to sort of get a bird's eye you
know a ground view of how things are
going
and you know at first it was quite a you
know
quite a dust up you know i'd walk into
you know a little bird company and you
know the guys are like what the hell are
you doing down here
well i said i'm the commander of this
outfit i'd like to think i could come
down here if i want but over time they
realized it was no threat i made sure i
never chewed anybody's ass when i was
down there it wasn't you know it wasn't
about that if i saw something
particularly egregious
i'd go back to the exo and say hey go
down to you know owens hangar and police
those dudes up i'm the good cop
you're the bad cop kind of thing but
what i would do is spend time with
troops and it was very low threat so i
get them around sit around and talk with
them
hey you know what can i do to make the
unit better
you know what do you think about are you
going i was a big pusher of off-duty
education because of my personal
background i knew how
you know how powerful it was and uh so
i'd always encourage them about that
and i'd look for easy wins low-hanging
fruit you know
like if there was something going on
that needed to be fixed but they were
just struggling through
you know multiple forms and triplicate
to get some crap done or something
then i would short circuit that and you
know i've shared this before with other
folks but
one day i was in the engine shop and we
were turning aircraft
from combat damage and you know
maintenance i mean it was
really we could barely keep up with what
we needed to have downrange
and i relied on these you know young 18
19 year old kids that were bore scoping
engines and you know doing stuff that
they had no idea of
probably their criticality to us
maintaining the right number of aircraft
to deploy but
i clearly knew so i you know i come into
their little engine shop this particular
time and i call them all in you know
round you know in fact uh
cindy meyer used to call it uncle clay's
story hour you know so i'd sit in there
and you know chat with him but i'd
always ask him hey
you know what what could i do you know
what can i do to
to make the unit better what can i do to
make your job easier
and this one young e4 said to me
you know sir i maxed my army physical
fitness test the apft
you know an army lingo and he said but i
got to go out and run
with like the slowest people out there
and formation run you know it's a bunch
of
garbage you know why don't we have an
incentive pt program which is pretty
common you know you score above a
certain
score and you you know you can sort of
do your own thing
and uh i said that's a good question let
me get back to you and that was about
one in the afternoon so i walked back up
to the headquarters got on an email sent
email out to the first sergeants and
said hey
do you have an incentive pt program
if you know if not why not and should we
have one
and they basically all wrote back and
said
yeah look we've been in combat we just
that kind of stuff has sort of fallen
off our radar
we should have one so you know i got
with the sar major
typed up a policy you know the agita
more accurately typed it up i signed it
and said if you get above whatever a 290
it's a possible score 300
you can pt on your own i walked right
back down about two hours later to that
same dude you know specialist i don't
know i don't remember his name
handed him the policy letter and said
hey
thanks you were right we should have
done this just fell off our radar you've
you know you
have changed battalion policy here is
our incentive pt program
you know of course that kid crowed about
that you know and i mean
six months later i'm hopping on a c-17
pulling a pump over to iraq and
this sergeant you know is i'm crawling
into my fart sack you know getting ready
to take my ambien
go to la la land and he uh he said hey
sir i just want to tell you
you know that kid still just brags about
changing policy
but you know little things like that the
force responds to that right they know
you give a damn
in which i do and um
you know they know they got a voice and
of course i didn't you know
you know why can't we have you know
women in the barracks you know blah blah
blah you know like you know why can't we
run a prostitution ring out here well
you know they're not going to get
everything you know but
you know i uh i tried to you know make
sure they understood they were
appreciated
and uh you know that doesn't mean i
don't hold the standard right i mean
you know you got to earn the right to be
in these units every day
and it ain't a job for life but i also
need
you know they they should have faith and
confidence in a chain of command we're
going to do the best we can
and be transparent as we can and you
know i think it worked pretty well
how about when you uh elevated up to
then regimental commander
a little harder right and it got
exponentially harder as a
general officer um but again now the
bureaucracy
increases more and now you know as a
battalion commander i'm down and in
right i mean i'm
i'm dealing with my boss a regimental
commander
but really my focus is combat right in
my unit
as the regimental commander at the time
i also had a humongous budget you know i
was the most
expensive 06 level command in the army
by orders of magnitude
by orders of magnitude we were also
geographically dispersed i have a
battalion up at fort lewis washington
4-160 i got a battalion in
savannah georgia three 160. i got two
battalions
uh operational battalions of fort
campbell plus a training battalion plus
an r d
outfit i've got guys all over the world
and i'm you know i'm an o6 so most of my
time that was the big changes now it's
up and out now i'm protecting my budget
right like
i'm the best looking woman at the frat
party i mean everybody wants to go out
with me they're trying to steal my cash
you know so i'm you know and i'm an o6
and i'm dealing with geos you know
um so it was much more resource
stuff i'm looking two or three ridge
lines down what do i need to do to make
sure that we're
adequately resourced and we remain you
know quoting general or admiral mcraven
we may not comparative maintain that
comparative advantage over our adversary
so that was my focus
that was the biggest difference it
wasn't down and in it wasn't combat
anymore
it was taking care of the regiment
down the road and making sure that they
had what they needed and that was really
this i mean that was a great training
ground for being a flag officer because
that's exactly what you know when you
were aiding for mcguire i bet most of
his stuff was resource stuff right yeah
oh yeah absolutely yeah yeah he was um
that's what that's what he that's what
he did that's what you do
yeah money title and
well i'm sure you know the navy the seal
teams don't always do well in that
category so it's rough sometimes
um and like you said especially when
you're going up you know against the air
force and just the the amount of
platforms that they have
is freaking rough yeah because they need
so much money for each one of those
platforms it's
it's like way more expensive than a boat
yeah yeah much more and i think now
though we're now where we got our we
sort of got our swim lanes right so we
you know we do we're rotary wing that's
what we do we do have
unmanned we got grey eagles which are
basically a predator
you know improved predator um
but you know we're very focused on what
we do assoc very focused on what we do
and you know going back to my tenure at
afsoc as a young captain those
relationships that i built with those
air force guys
really paid huge dividends later right
like i'm a personal friends with the air
force special ops commander jim slife
you know i mean he was the chief of
staff at socom when i was a three
you know we had a we have a personal
friendship scott howell out of fort
bragg were personal friends i mean when
i call them and say something it's
there's a trust factor
that goes both ways and it's with
numerous other
so i mean that made my life a lot easier
and really broadened my
sort of horizons as an officer realized
that you know hey it really does take a
joint force to get this done
and understand the different
perspectives you know
yeah we i was really my last deployment
was in was in ramadi
and just i mean yeah we wouldn't have
been able to do anything without the
army in the marine corps
to to have our back yeah qrf yeah all
that stuff
qrf kazzavac just every everything that
we needed
we needed from those guys they needed to
support us and we needed to support them
it was just an awesome relationship